Look out leggings and yoga pants!
A new jeans company is upping the comfortable legwear game...
...with a denim targeted at athletes.
Behold the "anti-thigh gap" jeans.
Hey everybody, I'm Lisa D'Souza with Buzz60.
A group of  fitness buffs in Nevada is designing jeans for the muscular body type.
The co-owner of Barbell Apparel says the group was, quote,...
..."tired of struggling with jeans that didn't fit and restricted our ability to move,"...
...adding these jeans are very much anti-thigh gap,...
...referring to a recent trend where girls strive to have a space between their upper thighs.
And Barbell Apparel says its pants do much more than just fit the athletic body type.
The jeans, made partially with spandex, are supposed to be comfy and flexible.
The ad claims you can do yoga, lift weights, kick a ball around,...
...even go for a run, all in the pants.
No word yet on what they smell like after that.
But the company's Kickstarter page is already raking in hundreds of thousands of dollars.
Who knew denim could prove to be competition for our sweats?
Buzz60.
Now you know, pass it on.